alors quand on m'a proposé de venir à
cette soirée je vous avoue que j'ai un
peu flipper un surtout en voyant le cv
des intervenants ce soir alors entre
celui qui a fait 50 mille bornes à vélo
celui qui a traversé l'atlantique tout
seul
et celui qui essaye d'aller sur mars
parce qu'il ya un cosmonaute aussi je
crois on dirait un peu le casting des
tares win a world je fais si vous
connaissez c'est ce palmarès des gens
dans des hommes l'impression générale ce
sont plutôt des mecs qui sont morts de
façon absurde
en voulant dépasser leurs limites alors
dans l'antiquité
ça avait un an 1,7 cette manie de
vouloir rivaliser avec les dieux on
appelait ça lui brice et la mythologie
grecque est pleine de ces héros qui en
voulant les plus hauts fini c'est
parfois aussi par ceux plantés
magistralement comme par exemple icare
qui en voulant voler près du soleil se
brûler les ailes et finit par tomber
dans la mer egée
alors heureusement les intervenants de
ce soir ont l'air de savoir ce qu'ils
font moi ça me rassure parce que j'étais
un peu inquiète pour eux en voyant mais
toujours est il que moi face à eux je me
suis senti comment dire plutôt limité un
car moi je tiens maximum dix minutes sur
un vélo d'appartement euros donc
unlimited eux c'est pas ma spécialité
je ne suis pas un héros comme dirait
balavoine bon et j'espère que je suis
pas la seule
j'espère que vous n'êtes pas tous des
grands sportifs ou des cosmonautes
sinon je me sentirai un peu seul imagine
l angoisse soirée cosmonaute
déjà tu as oublié ton costume et ensuite
là tout le monde te dis est alors toi
comment tu dépasse les limites je sais
pas mais il ya un point qui m'a semblé
quand même intéressant c'est que même
quand on est entre guillemets une
personne normale comme moi on est tout
de même confronté au fait que l'humanité
dépasse en permanence les limites du
possible
alors par exemple une fille de mon âge
elle peut aujourd'hui se poser des
question qui ne se posait pas avant
comme est ce que je devrais congelés
mais ovocytes ou carrément non congelés
moi même pour me réveiller dans un futur
meilleur où il n'y aurait ni mst ni
donald trump
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que le
progrès technique nous force à devoir
faire de plus en plus de choix
la question c'est pourquoi ça nous
angoisse et est ce qu'il faut pour
autant le limiter ce programme alors je
pense que non et je vais vous dire
pourquoi alors soyons clair aujourd'hui
les limites c'est ringard
quand on a la chance d'avoir un
passeport européen
on peut enfin on n'est plus vraiment
concerné par la notion de frontière
on peut ouvrir une crêperie en nouvelle
zélande ou agoa carrément sur la planète
mars à parce qu'aujourd'hui la planète
mars est presque aussi excessif que le
16e arrondissement enfin disons que
c'est une question de temps et de budget
ce que j'ai déjà par là c'est qu'on a
démystifié les distances et l'univers à
force de l'explorer à l'époque de blaise
pascal philosophe du xviie siècle
on craignait l'infini
autant qu on l'admirait le silence
éternel de ces espaces infinis m'effraie
dit il en contemplant le ciel étoilé
bon alors aussi parce qu'elles vivent
est aujourd'hui il ne regarderai plus et
les étoiles déjà parce que avec
éclairage urbain il verrait plus rien du
tout mais aussi parce qu'il serait
peut-être comme nous tous tétanisés par
la multiplicité des options qui
s'offraient à lui car aujourd'hui
l'infini est redescendu sur terre
plus précisément dans mon smartphone
c'est ce qui me frappe quand j'ouvre mon
portable
les millions de jobs auquel je pourrait
postuler sur linkedin l'iard deux types
avec lesquels je pourrais match et j'en
suis là le silence éternel de ce scrutin
fini mes frères alors vous me direz qu
est ce que ça a à voir avec la technique
un philosophe a réfléchi à tout ça c'est
jean jacques rousseau
pour lui l'homme est le seul parmi les
animaux à être perfectible
c'est à dire qu'il a la capacité de
devenir autre chose que ce qu'il a
d'aller plus loin plus haut de devenir
plus beau plus fort
harder better faster stronger comme
diraient les grands philosophes daft
punk que vous connaissez peut-être mais
cette paire édilité c'est pas forcément
un cadeau
pourquoi parce qu elle nous force à
devoir en permanence faire des choix
l'animal lui il est borné par son
instinct un pigeon il voit un reste de
sandwichs il fonce
il se dit pas ils se demandent pas
pendant des heures s'il pourrait trouver
du pain sans gluten dans une meilleure
boulangerie ou d'autres pigeonne sur
teen d'heure autrement dit il ne connaît
pas ce qui est devenu l'enfer notamment
de ma génération à savoir la tyrannie du
choix illimité dans la vie on est en
permanence en train de s'interroger de
s'interroger sur nos choix de se
demander si on n'est pas un peu pigeons
de rester dans cet appart dont les
charges sont trop chers ou dans cette
relation qui bat de l aile alors ça nous
permet de sortir de situations
désagréables mais c'est aussi ce qui
nous empêche de nous engager dans
l'action pourquoi parce qu'on a peur de
regretter décidé c'est tranché c'est
tracer la limite entre ce qui se sera et
ce qui ne sera plus et surtout ce qui ne
sera plus possible et ça c'est difficile
à avaler pour l'homme moderne
pourquoi parce qu'on nous serine en
permanence pour devrait être capable de
se réinventer à tout moment un peu comme
si on était une sorte de pâte à modeler
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des promesses du
transhumanisme de déconstruire ce qui
constituait finalement la limite ultime
à notre volonté à savoir le corps le
corps avant pour les philosophes c'était
la prison de l'âme
mais aujourd'hui
ces barreaux sont de plus en plus
malléable je peux me faire changer le
nez le sexe peut être l'argent pourrait
me faire poser des ailes on cherche même
à abolir le temps on imagine qu'on
pourra à 90 ans escalader l'himalaya et
qu'on aura des enfants à tout âge grâce
à l'utérus artificiel
le problème c'est qu'on n'est jamais sûr
que ces innovations sont forcément un
progrès quand rousseau dit que l'homme
est perfectible
il ne veut pas forcément dire que
l'humanité se perfectionne qu'elle
s'améliore au fil des siècles
car si l'homme est capable de dépasser
ses limites pour rousseau s'est certes
souvent pour le meilleur mais aussi
parfois pour le pire
le pigeon tout pigeons qu'il est il n'y
aura pas tuer son collègue pour lui
voler son iphone
l'homme si et c'est ce que vous savez
compris bien avant la shoah et la bombe
atomique
à savoir que le progrès moral ne va pas
forcément de pair avec le progrès
technique
du coup on se méfie du progressisme naïf
la croissance infinie
ça va deux secondes mais c'est pour
bousiller la planète c'est pas la peine
mais le risque c'est de tomber dans
l'excès inverse d'adopter les réflexes
conservateurs classique qui consiste à
vouloir un revenir en arrière et deux
fixer les choses à leur place
bon alors c'est pas un hasard si les
conservateurs adore les limites
il ya même une revue qui s'appelle comme
ça limite elle défend l'écologie
intégral qui si j'en crois leur
manifeste
souhaite que l'on respecte les limites
propres à chaque chose alors moi aussi
un jour n'est des limites
on en a tous j'essaie de pas manger trop
de chips et quand je sors j'essaie de
pas rentrée après 5 heures du matin on a
tous notre limite propre comme ça voilà
mon pour certains ces cinq heures pour
d'autres c'est 5 grammes mais dans tous
les cas quand il faut rentrer faut
rentrer oui si c'est parfois faut
rentrer mais là où ça devient plus
délicat c'est quand on essaye de définir
une sorte de nature des choses et
surtout de l'imposer aux autres
les objets par exemple c'est pas très
naturel on est à peu près tous d'accord
mais la contraception non plus alors du
coup qui décide qu'est-ce qu'on garde un
instagram le robot mixeur qu'est-ce
qu'on garde du progrès et surtout qui
décide christine boutin ou beyoncé moi
personnellement j'ai rien contre les
femmes qui sont prêtes à accoucher de 15
gosses sans péridurale dans une yourte
du moment qu'on ne me demande pas à moi
de revenir au moyen âge au nom d'une
nature qui serait soit disant bien fait
c'est toujours pareil le moment où ça
devient franchement limite ces cantons
finalement quand on tombe dans une sorte
de religion de la nature qui n'a plus
grand chose à voir avec l'écologie
avant on disait aux gens que les
souffrances les malheurs qui leur
tombait dessus les rages de dents les
famines
tout ça ça venait de dieu il fallait
donc l'accepter aujourd'hui on a
remplacé le concept de dieu par celui de
nature et c'est elle qu'on invoque quant
on trouve en gros que la technologie
c'est la porte ouverte à toutes les
fenêtres et qu'il faudrait surtout
retourner à une sorte d'ordre moral vous
voyez l'autre tentation c'est de vouloir
enfermer les choses et les gens dans des
espaces bien délimités dans son dernier
essai intitulé demeure
françois-xavier bellamy le nouveau
philosophe des conservateurs dont vous
avez peut-être entendu parler défend
l'idée qu'on a tous besoin de se
retrouver chacun chez soi dans un espace
où l'on sait qu'il en est alors avec un
tel programme c'est sûr qu'on est à
l'abri
pas de mcdo dans mon bled et pas de
réfugiés bon évidemment le risque c'est
qu'à force de rester à demeure on
deviennent tous un peu demeuré à force
de nous reproduire entre nous c'est
d'ailleurs étonnant que ce soit parfois
les mêmes personnes qui prônent un
retour à la nature et un rétablissement
des frontières comme si les barbelés
poussé à l'état sauvage
bref au fond le problème c'est qu'on a
peur de l'incertitude
je vous parlais tout à l'heure de pascal
pour lui on ne peut connaître ni l'homme
ni la nature
pourquoi parce qu'on en ignore l'origine
l'homme est dit il incapable de voir le
néant d'où il est tiré et l'infini dans
lequel il est engloutie ouais je sais
c'est beau parce qu'un nom et du coup on
se cherche des bases des assiettes ferme
de certitudes fin c'est ce qui dit une
assiette ferme de certitudes sur
lesquelles se reposer mais pas de chance
les limites branle dit pascal alors
calmez vous tout de suite quand pascal
dit ça c'est comme quand son collègue
montaigne dit que le monde les qu'une
branle loire pérenne
ce ne sont pas des cochoncetés 1 ça veut
juste dire que les choses changent qu'on
vit dans une sorte de changement
perpétuel et que c'est donc pas la peine
de s'accrocher à des vérités immuables à
des idéologies mais alors du coup qu'est
ce qu'on fait
le problème c'est que toutes ces
idéologies que ce soit le progressisme
comme le conservatisme finalement et
vite
de se poser les véritables questions qui
ne relèvent pas de la technique mais
plutôt de l'éthique dans la vie comme
dirait jean paul sartre on est condamné
à être libre a décidé qui l'on veut
devenir un comme lydie ou un type
bien
un état qui exclut ou une société qui
prend soin des individus mais ça ça
implique de se demander non pas jusqu'où
on va mais où on va
si la civilisation avancée sur terre que
comme un bolide sur une voie à sens
unique on aurait que deux options un
accélérer ou faire demi tour
ou sinon pique-niqué pour l'éternité
avec françois-xavier heureusement le
monde est plus complexe qu'un épisode de
fast and furious
et à force de voir le progrès comme une
autoroute à sens unique on oublier qu'on
est capable de bifurquer à tout moment
et surtout qu'on devrait vérifier
régulièrement on n'a pas oublié les plus
faibles sur la bande d'arrêt d'urgence
car il existe un autre infinie et je
vais terminer là dessus c'est l'infini
des possibles que recèle chaque instant
à chaque moment dans chaque initiative
que vous prenez vous creuser de
nouvelles pistes qui ouvre sur de
nouvelles voies qui elle-même débouche
sur de nouveaux chemins sur de nouvelles
idées auxquelles vous n'auriez peut-être
jamais pensé avant de vous engager dans
l'action c'est comme ça qu'on façonne la
société de demain en tâtonnant mais ça
ça implique
de faire face à cette infinie des
possibles autrement dit d'exercer notre
liberté
ça nous fait un peu peur mais ça vaut le
coup merci
[Applaudissements]